a
signant just where he was
needed claiming back as night
just in
the nobody is Los
it faces Merchant
change but your face remain the
same will be
when we're finally sober they'll be
gone the trees will Bloom the nights
will
melt we'll always remember how
so that was actually filmed about 3
weeks ago and yeah I'm trying to film
everything a little bit earlier so that
I can schedule a video and get a video
out every Friday so that's what I'm
aiming for hopefully that'll
happen yeah but uh since since all that
was filmed it's actually dried out here
a hell of a lot all the mats have dried
out including the path and I've moved
the electric fence that was all the way
down there so that they could have that
area and I've moved it over here so that
I can protect this bit of land here and
just let that grass recover a little bit
I don't think we're going to have to
lift the patio area I don't think those
mats are going to need releveling or
anything because they're fine but the
path yeah the path is a little bit
higgledy piggledy as you can see it all
sort of goes a little bit up at the
edges and down at other edges and it's
not very
flat so yeah I do think I'm going to
have to take that up
but what I'm going to show you first is
how Simon and Bruce fix the rails that
hope had broken on a main Paddock area
around the
Caravan that one's right
at that sh it straight up
does it
fit you know the idea of that hmer it's
called a pin hammer okay what you do is
you got a little Staple in between your
fingers see you can
hit in between your fingers without
bashing your fingers so you start it off
like that then you turn it around and
knock in did you bring your nail with
you staple can't get to there I staple
you got to give give me the stuff to use
I need the players as
well you're not going to bash my fingers
are you well I can't cuz you're using
that I don't know it depends how bad
your aim
is is your own really bad no
wait I like that one more go down here
like I did and you can hit it straight
on
then kneel down Crouch
down
brce you want me to start it and you can
finish it
off yeah I like that Watch How I do it
we I'm doing much different I'm pushing
up a little bit so come on you can
finish it off see if you can get it in
straight the rest of the
way get down a bit so you can your arms
Bel
yay go on try again
see I was getting lower and knocking it
upwards yeah but I'm small those easier
for you so why can I stand
up so you're still hitting downwards you
need to hit
upwards oh that'll do just knock it in
so it doesn't fall out it'll do the job
so they really did do a great job didn't
they and that's another thing tick off
that Hope Has dismantled that we've had
to fix do you know what if she didn't
break so many things then I reckon a lot
more would get done around here but well
that's the joy of having a heavy
cob another thing that Simon and ruce
was filled in the big holes at the side
of the stable that well they've been
there since we first got here and well
they needed filling in so they got on
with that too and this is how they did
it it's lap lch isn't it
no remember it can't remember what it's
called it is shiplap feather
shiplap shiplap
thick on that side thin on that side you
can see that and it is to replace this
section here that is
missing and this little square that's
just behind
Dream It's actually something that hope
didn't break they were just never there
in the first place and well if you've
been watching our Vlogs for a while then
you'll know that Bruce has done a few
little like And subscribe things through
them haven't you
Bruce don't forget to like And subscribe
to stay tuned for other videos we're
going to pull these now H or
the which
one
okay I love this
thing you my favorite' got that your
favorite tool and I forgot how to use it
I it is we all going to be able to use
it
what oh oh where did it go Bruce that's
your job have to get the
magnet have to drag it through the
dirt oh
God too
strong there it is
they're all 17
in how many do we
need
one I think turn that one
a bit
T kind a bit muches one underneath isn't
it bit St
so
I think the bottom look the bottom cuz
it was straight originally yeah is buted
up and then the top isn't because the
whole thing on I'm just going to try
and do it as straight as
possible hi
why does that say my
name hi
B
look oh no
that's all we've
got can't put a tiny piece
on you keep your window ho cuz some wood
wasn't quite long
enough well what a difference that makes
little things you know for the cost of I
think it was4 for that one board and
it's done all that and made that look so
much neater so that's
amazing right I'm going to have a go
getting these mates up now see if that's
possible and until next time bye-bye